ich sitze dann wirklich da okay da
meisten meinte schneider und kommt mir
nebenbei diese sehen wir an der epischen
legende wieder mit kompakter allah wenn
man ein krater hero herzlich willkommen
zurück
ich weiß endlich was ich mache ich habe
gerade eben noch viele kommentare
gelesen und mal in der offline version
geguckt als ja bei mir ne super flat map
erstellt und s-bahnen slams wie folgt
wie inseln gibt es bei uns nicht weil
wenn die version die richtige wäre
dieses leim inseln die spawnen sehr sehr
häufig wurde geschrieben das heißt sie
sind nicht da um euch noch niemals eine
gesehen habe sind die auch nicht da dann
spawnen slams eigentlich im sumpf bei
mondschein oder auf einer superflat map
ich hab mir grad ne super flat map
angemacht und mac os x 8 und da ist mir
aufgefallen ist james bond wirklich sehr
sehr wenig das heißt man muss sich schon
wirklich viel mühe geben damit und genau
das werde ich jetzt tun das heißt ich
weiß nicht ob das jetzt an mit allgemein
liegt aber es sind wirklich wenige slams
gewesen die sportiv aber die spanne auf
teller ebene
deswegen werde ich jetzt einfach so
machen dass ich hier unter meinem also
unter meinem haus jetzt so einen fetten
bereich mal wenn ich habe meine hammer
ich werde einfach ich weiß nicht ob das
hier ein slime krank ist aber man kann
davon ausgehen dass in einem drei mal
drei großen feld eins lang drin ist und
wenn nicht wird das so groß gemacht das
loch bis da ein verdammtes lang
you know how ich mich jetzt hier einfach
runter wird die ganze vor loch ausheben
weil ich muss das dann natürlich auch
automatisieren und damit ich dann ist
sehr sehr viele stammkräfte
was hatte ich in einer karriere als
youtube am meisten gefreut also welche
situationen das 200.000 abonnenten
erreicht hast dass du mit dem und den
kontakt getreten ist
das ist auch wieder so eine schwierige
frage
ich habe mich am meisten darüber gefreut
oder generell am meisten habe ich mich
über das jahr 2013 gefreut da waren
richtig viele momente die kann ich gerne
so erzählen das jahr 2013 habe ich das
gefühl das hat mein gesamtes leben
umgekrempelt weil das waren so viele
neue eindrücke dieser gekommen sind so
viele neue menschen meist ein neuer
eindrücke
ich habe ganz viele neue leute
kennengelernt war das erste mal in köln
auf der gamescom die ersten leute dann
auch mal so in real gesehen mich mich
auch gar nicht doch auf dem video der
weil es aber nur ganz kurz alte was ihr
so vornehmen um zum allgemeinen vögel zu
kommen was ich mir vornehme vision mit
der dezenten verspätung eingetroffen
halbe stunde war ich zu spät
ja das war leider dazu kam zu spät und
die deutsch fahrer schuld einfach alles
deutsche bahn und danach voller porsche
wo es mal typisch und so kam ich dann an
kam mir das auch schon so leute entgegen
und das ist jedoch kein ob das war auch
seine heftiger moment der mich geprägt
hat ein mädchen hat geweint als sie mich
gesehen hat das ist das war richtig
richtig komisch und ich bekam nicht klar
mit der situation ich wusste nicht was
ich dann machen sollte diese sind in
dieser situation wo ich war dann quasi
der bei diesem mädchen am video day und
ich bin da einfach mal vorbei kann die
hat mich zwar so komisch angeguckt aber
das passiert halt in der schule auch
täglich das mich so leute die mich
eventuell kennen komisch angucken oder
auch mit
in der stadt bern wollte ja klar dass
schule ist der heftigste jemals in der
schule ist es so jeder vor allem wenn
sie dann willst du so erhöhe die habe
ich teilweise abonniert aber die kennen
mich halt einfach nur das ist halt weiß
nicht welchen kraftakt kuchen abhaben
die die gucken die gucken die so
hinterher und rufen dann wird conny dann
dreht sich um mal gucken diese schnell
weg und so weiß nicht was ich ja nicht
immer angenehm oder sagt jörg f ich will
mich um noch mal keiner war irgendwann
mein namen gesagt dass er sich sicher
ich bin noch nicht paranoid ich finde
dass ich finde das richtig unangenehm
wie in der schule voll wenn du mit
deinen freunden
darum läuft und dann kommen solche
solche leute da ich weiß nicht ich fühle
mich danach richtig komisch weil also
ich freue mich immer wenn leute mich
ansprechen ganz viele leute schreiben
wir dann auch bei facebook
ja ich hab dich heute gesehen aber nicht
getraut dich anzusprechen wie nicht
angesprochen so nicht dass sich die
chili würde das finde ich besser als
einfach nur zum beispiel in der zf arena
besser ansprechen so wenn man irgendwie
da so ist blabla dies das aber wenn man
irgendwie was man krieg ich nicht kann
ich nicht theoretisch wecken nicht okay
was ich nicht ab kann ist wenn leute
wenn ich damit meinen mit meinen
freunden unterwegs bin dann schreiben
wir dass leute einfach hinterher
sowas mag ich gar also wenn die conny
gang unterwegs ist conny anderen clans
die backen zu halten er wahrscheinlich
der amboss der hier mal bei dir stand
ist kaputt macht schillig 19 mann ich
weiß nicht ob ich irgendwann hab' aber
ist wirklich kaputt gegangen deswegen
hab ich kein neun mal gemacht
dann packe ich jetzt mal die schuhe
waren also ja traf ihr wirklich die
ganze folge jetzt deswegen ist es ganz
gut dass lokalitäten vorbereitet hat das
fahren als ein paar dinge die mich in
diesem jahr geprägt haben
das rad kann ich war so gar nicht
erzählt also nicht nur video day oder
sondern war das und wie alles ganz
entwickelt das ging von schlag auf
schlag für die sie sich noch erinnern
ich hatte ja glaube ich anfang des
jahres 2013 hat sich 20.000 abonnenten
und ende 2013 hatte ich eine
viertelmillion was du denkst oh wow das
ist
findet auch manchmal voll krass ich weiß
nicht wie das bei dir ist aber so alle
sagen immer so ab jetzt richtig
besonders für fünf millionen und so viel
sei schon wieder obama war in lüttich
straßen gest aber ich weiß nicht das ist
so es ist wie so eine zahl was ich finde
wenn ich so diese diese zahl vor augen
habe das halt sehr sehr viele leute ein
abonniert haben
dann denkst du halt immer so warum das
frage ich mich immer ich mache mein okay
die erhöhung dann einen vielleicht und
so die mögen die videos und für die
zuschauer ist es leicht zu erklären
jajeh der kfd ist ganz gut in hero oder
der koch das jetzt wirklich oder beim
mdr der macht mal so coole videos und
blablabla der solar eigene meinung hat
aber jetzt ganz genau warum ihr gerade
mich abonniert haben und dann in so
einer masse kann ich mir gar nicht
erklären
das ist bei mir richtig komisch ich kann
es mir echt nicht erklären oder könntest
du jetzt irgend einen triftigen grund
sagen ja ich würde mich selbst auch
abonieren ja und sich zwar ist mir aber
das gefühl hat sich auch was du
geschrieben hast aber nicht ich habe mir
ein neues projekt ausgedacht und zu kann
aber ich habe also skype blog projekte
sommer solo halt damit sie wenn ich mir
fotos aufnehmen muss wegen der uni das
will ich machen kann und habe ich so was
ins leben gerufen nennt sich tags keil
ob das heißt ich bin dann auf der insel
mit allen möglichkeiten
ja ich hab mir das ist richtig verrückt
manchmal ich hab mir ich hab die folge
aufgenommen fertig gerenderten geladen
und danach gucke ich mir meine eigene
folge ganz bei youtube an was ohne bis
ich gucke mir meine eigene serie ganz
bei youtube an
und ich finde sie richtig witzig ich war
wie ohne wird dass wir noch nie das ist
mir war keiner ich gucke nicht alle
meine jünger folgen oder sony com ist
ein kinder regel gar nicht an
aber da würde ich die einzige sehen ich
sitze dann wirklich da okay da meisten
meint schneider
und kommt mir nebenbei diese sehen wir
an
es ist einfach vorzieht sich selbst an
das genauso wie wenn man den spiegel
guckt denken alles also wenn du bei dem
projekt so ich weiß nicht ist das geil
alle denken ziemlich eingebildet und so
können sie deine eigenen videos ist aber
einfach nur mega witzig mein gott ich
nie gedacht ist das geil ich gehört dass
alle mal in basel hat das video hoch und
basteln da ist es leute anguckt aber
dass diese meist durch google selbst
über mein gold will ich cool geschafft
weil wir die frage mal lassen wir ich
stärke noch an lachen ganz einfache
frage benutzte die bei facebook oder
lieber twitter und kommt so merkel
ich muss ehrlich gesagt sagen da muss
ich wieder ein bisschen weiter ausholen
ich hab die ganzen social media sachen
erst übels spät alle kennen gelernt und
dann mir hat niemals jemand also
facebook ergibt sich von sich selbst
halt klar
aber so was wie twitter wird niemals
jemand richtig gezeigt wie man richtig
twittert ich weiß ich weiß nicht wie das
geht
ich habe das irgendwie mit youtube
verbunden dass wenn ich dann was gleich
oder so dass man das dann auch twitter
sieht aber manchmal habe ich dann da mal
was sein gepostet oder so aber so an
sich ich habe keine ahnung wie twitter
funktioniert ja bei mir ist es so
jetzt wissen traurig an eigentlich ne
ich nutze zurzeit immer lieber twitter
immer mehr was die vorteile bei twitter
ist es so du kannst du für uns wie du
willst und keiner beschwert sich mögen
wenn du richtig viel spams aber bei
facebook ist es immer so wenn ich bei
facebook irgendwas schreibe denke ich
mir ich hab heute schon drei sachen
gepostet lass mal lieber das denkst
nicht mehr facebook immer da war wie
instagram insider also die frage sie auf
facebook und twitter bezogen erstmal
instagram kann man danach noch gleich
eingehen
aber weil twitter spell der post ich
mittlerweile soviel zb ich habe gestern
einfach mal so just for fun germany's
next topmodel gibt habe dabei so ein
bisschen einfach so gepostet so das sage
ich nicht nein ich hab ich lach mich
immer eagles darüber kaputt dass die
alle da also in szene schieben wenn zum
beispiel auch keine ahnung so richtig
komisch ja und dann habe ich einfach mal
ein bisschen getwittert und dann also
geschrieben so weiß nicht kannst ja
nachher gucken was sie getötet habe
aber da sind dann auch wirklich direkt
rezension gekommen so läuten und dann
meinten die soja finde ich auch und
blabla da kann es einfach viel besser
auf die leute eingehen weil jetzt ist
das weiß nicht ich finde auch dass das
ist irgendwie richtig komplett wird
dabei twitter hatte kanzler hashtag
james ex topmodel schreiben dann ist es
soweit in dieser gruppe mehr oder
weniger drin so wie jetzt die tweets
jetzt die uns gerade als fragen gesendet
werden und ich standen was hat dieses
add und dieses hashtag mit twitter zu
tun wenn ich zum beispiel direkt sowie
strecken konkret wenn ich jetzt
konkreter mache dann sieht man dass auf
meiner seite und auf deiner nähe aber
ich bekomme eine benachrichtigung dass
es halt an mich ist sowieso eine frage
aber wenn du zum beispiel hashtag macht
es ist halt das geilste was es gibt
du kannst ein hashtag machen wie zum
beispiel als lp mit conny dann gibt es
über twitter hashtag lp mit conny 1
und dann sind unter dem hashtag rp mit
conny alle themen über die wir gerade
reden das ist halt das geile an twitter
und das geil ist auch dass du direkt
verletzt bist dass du das die ganze
stars und so was heißt das also ich
folge jetzt keine stars aber ich sag
jetzt mal so pipa oder so die post
maturafach ich mag es ich mag es mega
gerne
ich mag mega gern wie blogs oder follow
me round oder wenn leute einfach so
spontan foto machen und das ist einfach
bei twitter so bei facebook ist es immer
so war twitter fotos erkannt wird auch
land wirklich
na klar dass das geht nur über instagram
alter ich bin ja die leute denken sie
echt guckt sie erstmal in seinem dunklen
kämmerlein seiner eigenen videos an und
ist übels abgeschieden von der welten
löst bei dir wirklich lösen er weiß
nicht zur zeit
ich mag ich immer mehr twitter lieber
deswegen passt ja immer seltener was auf
facebook
aber vielleicht geht es doch immer
wieder eine andere richtung ich mach
instagram muss ich sagen er instagram
ist wo ich mich aber wissen durch
rappeln musste weil ganz viel habe ich
mir einfach cap kannst du nicht das
passt und dass man posten ich habe das
immer so ein bisschen genannt hat sich
mal böse an
wenn ich zu sagen so viele freunde
hatten das oder so da hab ich einmal
gesagt sie ja facebook opfer war immer
so gesagt weil da sind dann leute die
irgendwie jeden zweifel hat in die hose
gekackt foto kostet so zum beispiel und
das habe ich dann immer übrigens
aufgeregt aber wirklich übel weiß meine
ja klar ist was gespart das jetzt so wie
instagram und so mich die leute gefragt
haben da kannst du mal was posten dann
das war richtig schwer für mich mich da
wissen so daran zu gewöhnen überhaupt
was zu posten weil ich dachte mir so nah
hast dich davor mal lustig gemacht und
jetzt postete selber sage ich mal nicht
jeden scheiß aber so konnte manchmal so
vor weiß ja ja ich weiß was du meinst
bei mir ist es auch so dass ich das auch
immer noch tue und zwar ist es halt
einfach so dass jedes netzwerk seine
typischen leute sag ich mal hat über die
man sich einfach nur aufregt bei
instagram sind das immer im fall die
leute die einfach über jedes bild
schreiben follow me ich voller zurück
alles mögliche oder das ich mag nerve
ich mag auch nicht irgendwie sie das
jetzt komisch an und irgendwie
beleidigend vielleicht auch aber ich mag
irgendwie nicht diese kommentare einfach
so nach einer sekunde cool einfach so
cool das hat die höhlenmaler in cool
findet das bild cool aber ich finde es
hat gar kein belang zu dem bild das
finde ich auch so ein bisschen komisch
ist zwar schön dass sie kommentiert und
alles aber einfach so cool drunter oder
einfach so klasse oder einfach letztes
jahr doch einfach so conny und das war
es einfach nur geil
weiß nicht es hat uns der liebe heißt
das weiß ich endlich wie ich heiße ich
heiße nicht konnte ich als luca mal
innehalten aber twittern ihr ich weiß
garnicht conny mir wirklich so nicht
also jedes netzwerk bei facebook sind
dann die leute die einfach alles
mögliche posten oder die griechen alle
gruppen einladen alle veranstaltungen
oder die sich alle zwei stunden
profilbild ändern die alle möglichen
sachen leiden also das ist einfach
klasse gar nicht mehr
aber es geht ich kenne solche ich nenne
das einfach mal unfreundlich auch also
nicht so böse gemeint ich habe so eine
aussprache sag ich mal so ein
semantischer co es gibt so ich denke
manchmal so das sind so ads mädchen hat
iris mädchen ja dass die posten einfach
so ein foto oder mehr als eine davon
keine ahnung und somit back fence oder
so da was weiß ich was wo ich mir denke
alter dass sie übels scheiße aus
schneiden einfach mal 15 freundinnen so
von wegen
roswitha baby allerbester erwartet
dann bin ich noch schreibe ich drunter
mittag face sieht scheiße aus
ich habe mich direkt darunter normal
sich die hübsche aus und dann kümmern
übelste hates werde arbeiten zu sehen
ich hab schon gar nichts mehr bleiben
ja das sind außer sachen die ich einfach
nie verstehe
ach ja weise nicht meine wenn man wissen
will noch was gut aussieht kann das ja
machen aber meine klagen jetzt mal so
ein foto hochlädt beispiel was soll ich
habe färben ja nein man sich selber und
schließlich ist gut kann man machen aber
immer diese spezielle fotos nur damit
sage ich mal die freundinnen in anflug
sehen wir uns dann wir überlegen müssen
ob das wirklich freundinnen sind nur
dann schreiben sie wieder was nicht auch
das ja super
klasse
das toll gemacht mehr also nicht dass es
gibt in jedem netzwerk diese leute aber
bei twitter habe ich die halt noch nicht
so entdeckt bei twitter finde ich bisher
habe ich bei twitter noch keine leute
entdeckt wo ich mir wirklich sage war
das nicht so
kritiker wie tweed dem ich dass das ist
eigentlich bei jedem netzwerk kann etwas
tun fans begleiten instagram
leichenteilen schau dort keine ahnung so
richtig viele sachen aber bei instagram
finde ich diese es gibt jetzt keine ich
kenne keine person bisher vorgegangen
geschrieben hat connery trittin mich
oder so jetzt kommt jetzt konnte also
okay ich konnte mich mit meinem ist port
stabhoch zaubern wieder
aber ich habe glaube ich den einzigen
dann zugebaut den ich hab' ich bin
gerade dabei meine kisten zu sortieren
ich glaube ich bin gleich fertig
wirklich werde er ich bin jetzt richtig
an durchziehen gewesen hier also ich hab
ich auch langsam voran gewordene sachen
einfach weggeschmissen locker zwölf
kisten weggeschmissen wir einfach weiß
wo dann sieht's drin sind und so was was
ich brauche dich fleischfresser und soll
ich habe hier eine bau kiste da sind
auch wertvolle sachen die welt dann in
der nächsten folge noch ein paar sachen
die ich einfach nicht brauche es ja auch
weg tun weil ich will hier jetzt
durchstarten und zwar mache ich mir
jetzt eine vorteil für nach unten weil
ich hasse es so man hat hat kann ich mit
einer aluminium nugget machen mit einem
judith luig
man muss nur neun stück von sammeln
kannst du doch von ihm gut machen
ein stück das heißt er ist nicht so viel
wert
ja ok multivac sack und pack so eine
frage müsste noch gehen
ja denke ich auch
ich muss nur gucken wie ich mich nach
unten teleport hier weil mich meine
pocket menschen da bin ich irgendwie
schon so eingespielt wie es gut wenn
schule keine pflicht wäre würdet ihr
trotzdem hin gehen aufgrund der bildung
auf jeden fall
ich glaube ich will auch hingehen das
ding ist ich muss sagen dies gut ich hab
eine tür falsch gesetzt
ich habe meine tür in der partitur ihn
gesetzt ohne die anständig zu verbinden
das heißt ich musste jetzt abbauen
aber dann kommt ein recht und wer will
ein poeta menschen auffressen auffahrt
auf alter was machst du jetzt erst mal
okay wir erstmal was aus muss ja was
ausprobieren was soll ich machen
er hat man gehört dass ich aufgestanden
bin ja was soll ich denn machen ach ja
ich war meine baumaterialien
zusammensammeln meine teilen wenn der
auch käßmann hat kannst du eigentlich
jetzt habe ich hier ein rift erstellt
habe ich ein referat bitte bitte bitte
bitte lass uns plate gemacht nein das
ist ich hab ein reformer wird das muss
funktioniert wie gesagt dadurch habe ich
schon mein halbes haus verloren
ziemlich einfach kein cobblestone werner
wie privat ein wo ist ein hammer
so ist rima hier also ich finde es schon
sehr viele wieder geschafft jetzt bald
nur noch volkes jetzt auch schon wieder
vorbei kämpfen auch meiner meinung nach
ein bisschen überziehen
ich werde bald die häuser auch endlich
zu ende bauen wir auch endlich zu ja da
ist doch kaka aber hier habe ich jetzt
ein paar kisten stehen und hier die hier
muss ich noch einräumen
nach der kombi kräftig nachgeben einmal
reinpacken das ist echt mies also kann
sie das gar nicht vorstellen wohl
stechen crafting dreifach hier sind ja
ich dass wir erst mal da stehen so dann
kommen die rüstungs oder nehme ich jetzt
mal ganz kurz nämlich mein inventar mit
welchem alter problem ist einfach aber
jetzt auch wieder im voraus aufnehmen
haben wir ja für ein paar tage nämlich
aber nach drei tagen hin kommen ohne
dass jetzt anständig abzubauen
dann ist es einfach mal so dass das
jetzt mal ein ganzes haus noch
weggefressen wurde wieder weggefressen
und das ist mies nicht versucht einen
auf frage hier wirklich auf jeden fall
nicht mehr aufnehmen
eine folge schaffen nicht mehr dass die
letzte und die ist jetzt auch vorbei
eigentlich erwarte ich hab es glaube ich
gerade geschafft hier war das rift war
da aber mich nicht nur fressen
ich glaube ich schaffe es doch conny
conny nämlich nicht luca nämlich conny
hier sind übrigens mein award die partie
jetzt auch ihren auf mit allem was muss
nur knapp ich bin so dankbar männer
willkommen zurück mein bauch ist dann
beende ich meine folge für horn ja klar
was ich noch ich wollten reduzieren
gezwungen hier muss nur ganz kurz noch
einen rest rimowa kräften weil ich muss
die tür abbauen ich will nicht riskieren
dass da irgendwas passiert wirklich
nicht ja klar kann es machen so zeigt
okay okay okay so dass und vier gold
drumherum dann war ein riff rimowa diese
tür die kann ich nämlich eigentlich
nicht da lassen weil die ich stimmt
nicht so ich habe man denkt ich habe in
dieser folge wenig geschafft aber ich
habe viel geschafft nein also ich habe
viele kisten
sortiert hier was heißt sortiert und
bisschen halten ich habe viele sachen
einfach weggeschmissen
wir haben super fragen beantwortet find
ich richtig richtig geil
das recht auch so gerne fragen bei
ankamen münchen riem ufer ist gar nicht
kaputt gegangen beim rufen jetzt habe
ich noch mehr angst aber sonst würde ich
sagen meine lieben freunde ja ich musste
einfach jedoch belasten wenn meine
pocket menschen komplett weggefressen
wird ist der leider weg ansonsten leute
bitte schreibt mir die kommentare wie
das ministry of sound auf sich hat
schaut man jeweils anderen vorbei bleibt
geilomat bis dann